economía en france 24 conmigo en el
estudio de niell a blandón daniela buena
noche de bienvenida comencemos hablando
por supuesto la noticia del día los
detalles más polémicos de la
investigación del periódico new york
times sobre los impuestos de unalt son
bueno pero no ya es un medio distintas
en sí señor raúl muy buenas noches pues
la información exclusiva que publicó el
diario estadounidense es detalla a 18
años de vida fiscal del presidente con
contribuciones mínimas deudas
millonarias y dudosas prácticas fiscales
los datos dejaron sorprendido a más de
uno raúl por ejemplo que en la
declaración de impuestos del primer año
como mandatario sólo tuvo que pagar 750
dólares otro detalle polémico tiene que
ver con una devolución por casi 73
millones de dólares que habría recibido
por impuestos pagados entre 2005 y 2007
pero quizás uno de los más curiosos fue
la deducción que hizo de gastos como 70
mil dólares en cuidado del cabello y
otros 100 mil dólares en el estilista de
su hija ivanka y sus deudas personales
por más de 400 millones de dólares
también dieron de qué hablar a well
así de janiel entonces vamos ya con otra
información pero en eeuu porque
finalmente la casa de la casa se una a
la empresa cubana que canaliza las
remesas desde hace varias semanas se
viene hablando del tema sin embargo sólo
hasta hoy el secretario de estado mike
pompeo hizo el anuncio a pocos días de
haber prohibido a los ciudadanos
alojarse en hoteles estatales de la isla
con la nueva sanción
los estadounidenses no podrán hacer
ninguna transacción con la empresa de
remesas american international services
cuya matriz es la estatal sin simex
controlado por el ejército este es un
sistema con el que los cubanos reciben
dinero de sus familiares en el exterior
lo hacen con una tarjeta que también les
sirve para pagar en algunos
establecimientos raúl la respuesta del
gobierno cubano es que éste no es más
que un intento de manipulación de la
administración trump hacia los electores
de la florida inició una nueva y
definitiva ronda de negociación del
acuerdo postres y daniela vamos a europa
ahora si raúl pues londres y bruselas se
encaran esta semana lo en un intento de
definir las relaciones comerciales
el próximo primero de enero esto después
del divorcio del 31 de enero pasado las
mismas partes han reconocido que si no
es este mes no es nunca ya que este
acuerdo debe ser ratificado en los
parlamentos a la unión europea todavía
le queda una esperanza a pesar de los
pocos avances escuchemos a honduras
points bulletin listo hago un llamado a
la responsabilidad en estos tiempos
porque nuestras economías están
severamente afectadas por la pandemia
vaya panda make the details
on the table los detalles están claros
sobre la mesa así que de nuestro lado la
voluntad dar un paso adelante y llegar a
un acuerdo es clara you have the wee man
skream el gobierno de francia presentó
su proyecto de presupuesto para el año
2021 sí señor los dos pilares de este
plan son la descarbonización de la
economía y también la recuperación post
pandemia en principio francia liberará
unos 42 mil millones de euros en
estímulos económicos durante 2021 para
eso se va a necesitar que el déficit
público pues siga alto al igual que la
deuda pública
antes de la pandemia raúl la economía de
este país era más grande que sus deudas
pero como todo cambio ahora se estima
que en 2021 la deuda será equivalente al
116 por ciento del producto interno
bruto una de las metas es que el próximo
año haya un crecimiento económico del 8
por ciento frente a una recesión del 10%
en 2020 así dejan y la pasamos ahora a
los indicadores del día un día de fiesta
en las principales bolsas del mundo raúl
todo por cuenta del nuevo paquete de
estímulos que posiblemente se apruebe en
eeuu están en concierto o street tuvo
buenas ganancias pero no tan altas como
las de las bolsas europeas alemania y
parís fueron las de mejor resultado y en
américa latina' pérdidas en la bolsa de
sao paulo que este año ya no recibirá a
la aseguradora caixa y a la energética
compás como nuevos emisores esto por el
deterioro económico asia genera ya para
finalizar entonces este bloque económico
le pregunto por nuestra cifra al día
mire son aprovechando el tema del día
son los 11.165 dólares que según joe
bites en pago en promedio cada estado
unidad
en impuestos durante 2017 la campaña del
candidato demócrata a la presidencia
diseñó una calculadora muy singular con
la que cada quien puede medir cuánto
pagó más que el presidente de donald
trump en este periodo funciona muy
sencillo se restan los 750 dólares que
pagó el primer mandatario ese año y ahí
sale el resultado daría las gracias
ustedes saben gracias continuar con
nosotros
[Música]